here's what's going on at the movies I  want to build a team of some very bad  people who I think can do some good  don't miss action-packed superhero fun  in two aside squad starring Will Smith  Jared Leto and Margot Robbie now playing  in IMAX that's a good idea Mike sue me  can I just pick out a cat and I'll be on  my way how do I get out of this nine  live stars Kevin Spacey as a businessman  trapped in the body of a cat until he  can learn to be a better person show  them I'm humans just drown me I know I  am Matt Damon is back in the action  thriller Jason Bourne which finds the  former assassin searching for the truth  about his contribution  and finally let's find out what's hot in  theaters this weekend with this week's  fantasy patience  so what's your weekend ticket going to  be let us know in the comments below  we'll see you next time on weekend  ticket  you